años después el mundo sigue percibiendo
las consecuencias de una guerra que era
innecesaria y que se llevó los recursos
de una región junto con su estabilidad
Además desde poner en cuestión el
concepto de la guerra preventiva de
Estados Unidos el análisis es con el
Lucas a Martín él es analista de
inteligencia Y seguridad y autor de los
libros visión global y terror global
Muchas gracias Lucas por estar con
nosotros y comienzo preguntándole si le
parece
Qué tal Buenas tardes Muchas gracias
para comenzar Cómo cambió el papel de
los países y cómo evolucionamos al
concepto de Las Guerras Proxy a partir
de los fracasos en Irak y en Afganistán
bueno el gran problema de Irak siempre
ha sido como Comenta usted
la influencia de los grupos proxys en
este caso de Irán a raíz de la invasión
y después la ocupación del país eso
generó un vacío de poder hay que
recordar que Estados Unidos
despidió a todos los funcionariado y a
todos los miembros de las fuerzas
armadas iraquíes y la fuerza de
seguridad y eso creo un vacío de poder y
un vacío de seguridad que fue ocupado
poco a poco por esos grupos Proxy tiran
Porque Irán yo ahí una oportunidad de
ganar influencia en el país lo cual se
unió además al aumento de actividad de
alcaidas y después a partir de 2006 de
la aparición del estado islámico
bueno Estados Unidos sigue siendo el
policía del mundo Pero ha cambiado su
forma de involucrarse en los conflictos
lo podemos ver ahora mismo con lo que
está sucediendo en Ucrania y lo mismo
para otras potencias Por qué irá marcó
un hito importante en el cambio de la
manera de manejar por ejemplo la
política exterior
Bueno hay que recordar también que en
esa época Estados Unidos estaba muy
centrado en Oriente en próximo Oriente
era una zona para yo fundamental y con
el tiempo y finalizado con la
administración Obama se decidió dejar
esa zona y prestar más atención a otras
regiones Como por ejemplo la región Asia
Pacífico la comparación que se hace
ahora mismo con la actitud o la forma de
actuar de Estados Unidos en este
conflicto en Irak y lo que sucede ahora
en Ucrania no es del todo vamos a decir
acertada porque en este caso entra en
juego otros factores entra en juego el
peligro de escalada con la organización
con una organización como es la otan
cosa que no sucedía en entonces con Irak
y también me gustaría recordar que
cuando Estados Unidos interviene a pesar
de evidentemente la justificación que se
demostró después que no que no era tal
lo hace bajo el amparo de una resolución
de Naciones Unidas que es la 1441 que
combinaba a Irak a desarmarse y fue
aprobado además por el consejo de
seguridad en noviembre
y por unanimidad
usted estaba hablando hace un momento de
la intervención de Irán que empezó a
darse después de la invasión de Estados
Unidos quisiera por favor que nos
ampliara un poco sobre el papel de los
iraníes y de los sirios durante todos
los años de la invasión
Bueno más que Siria yo lo haría dirán
Irán siempre históricamente ha tenido
vamos a decir como objetivo como un área
Sur e influencia y ha intentado
influenciar en la política iraquí y a
pesar de que por ejemplo en su día
homeni antes de regresar a Irán para que
fuera la revolución estuvo en nayajá
acogido durante varios años pero desde
que tomó el poder en Irán como en fin
intentar influenciar la política ir aquí
con sus grupos proxys eso derivó en la
famosa Guerra del Golfo en teirán e Irak
y después siempre que tenga ocasión ha
intentado influir de hecho los últimos
acontecimientos que tuvieron lugar hace
tres años y no recuerdo mal con intento
de asalto a la Embajada Americana y que
provocó una crisis bastante importante
fue propiciada porque el gran parte del
pueblo era Aquí estaba digamos opuesto o
se oponía como a 40 ustedes además antes
a esa influencia iraní no quieren
influencia ni de Estados Unidos pero
tampoco iraní Y eso es un mal endémico
que sufre el país y que es uno de los
grandes lastres que le impide avanzar